good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy
Wednesday it is hump day do not forget
to hump someone you love because that's
what we do here at the morning toast and
speaking of girlies I wouldn't mind dry
humping okay I took a little too far
sorry hey Jax how you doing
I'm doing good I'm feeling conflicted
first you make fun of my lingering s in
Millennials Me and Jackie were talking
about this yesterday like when we say
good morning Millennials Jackie always
holds out the ass and when we're editing
the episode it actually makes it really
difficult to
um like line up our vocals so if you
could just like cut the s
I'll think about it I just want to hold
on to that moment I love the moment of
course I love wishing all of the
Millennials and gen Z
and Boomers uh good morning I think it's
such an important way that we start our
day and maybe that's not something that
we agree on
but now you want to dry hump me which is
not what I want for us either sisters
not sisters that's not sisterly Tings no
but like sisterly things like you make
fun of your sister and then like you
love her oh for sure and then you tell
her to get on the leap of faith oh my
God I'm so hating that we brought that
up I'm loving it I got reached I got
Outreach from both the sisters saying
that they're so glad that I told the
story
wait speaking of stories I remembered
something last night that needs to be
added to my list of stories that I am
constantly saying okay
checking it twice yesterday we added
Trevor Noah's big ass right
oh yeah not officially though Trev oh no
that's your regrets
Trevor Noah's big ass okay okay and
here's another one you're gonna like
you're gonna really feel it this is like
a quintessential like me story like what
we cannot talk about Serena Williams
because of the paper that you wrote
unless I'm going to talk about the paper
that I wrote that I actually got an A on
oh yeah no if we're gonna if I'm gonna
choose a story about Serena Williams we
need to carve out like five minutes for
Claudia to tell her story
you don't understand what a big deal it
was like it was the final essay for this
class like I couldn't graduate without
it it wasn't like a dissertation but it
was like a 20-page paper and I forget
what the call the class was called it
was like race and ethics or something
and I trust her yeah whatever it was
like it was a daring choice because it
was contemporary you know and I think
most of my peers were were diving deep
into history and I decided to tell a
contemporary story it was a risk but
you're nothing if not a risk taker
and an academic
yeah so the list of stories is getting
really long we are actually recording a
hysterical patreon episode today our
fifth episode of the month where Claudia
is going to tell each story again in
depth I personally well one it's for
everyone who hasn't been around since
the beginning of each story and maybe
forgot bits and pieces so each story
she's gonna have the floor to tell her
tale I personally am hoping that it's
going to be closure and that you know
once you get to say them no in long form
that like we never have to hear some of
them again I mean I'm just looking
forward to the opportunity to
um to be given that opportunity to just
kind of
speak without judgment you know about my
favorite stories yeah no I wonder how
that feels I wouldn't know either no
speak without judgment about my favorite
things
I think you would know no I don't think
that I would well I think that's kind of
the life we chose as podcasters like to
speak with judgment you know
so true so I'm just gonna put the call
out I have a huge list of stories that
are Claudius faves but if anything comes
to mind for you and we also can check
the Instagram post of Claudia's favorite
stories or even something that you just
like want Clarity on that we always
reference probably number one is
Dennis's funeral then drop it in the
comments we'll include it in the episode
I'm really so excited I'm excited too
um because you know these are my
favorite stories for a reason yeah all
of them have like a very significant
moral of the story oh Hilary Duff at the
Bahamas yeah I mean that one's famous I
feel like everyone knows the time she
attacked me but um it can't hurt to say
it again
and by the way that Bahamian trip was
when you did the leap of faith oh yes oh
my God so I saw Hillary tough in
Atlantis and that was the time I went
back with my friends from high school
for spring break and we saw Hillary Duff
and I did that stupid water slide so
it's really it's full circle so what
you're saying is you took two leaps of
faith on that trip and both of them were
not worth it both of them were a flop
both of them were a big floppio
damn I'm sorry
it is what it is Jax it is sometimes you
take a leap of faith and you only hear
about the good leaps that people take
but there's a lot where you don't land
on anything well that's like the whole
concept even though like I don't
subscribe to The Narrative of like
needing to go to college to
um be successful but like that's the
world we live in where like people are
always saying like Bill Gates dropped
out of college like well that might be
true so did a lot of other people who
didn't become Bill Gates you know right
right
so I guess the message of today's
episode is stay in school even though
school is for suckers oh my God I was
just saying I would say stay in um stay
in school up up through high school I
think college is very optional I hope so
um also I just saw this Tick Tock that
was so funny because I have a whole bit
in my show about like things that
teachers used to say that's like so
[ __ ] annoying it makes no sense and
somebody was like sharing a video about
like the most annoying things teachers
used to say and it was hope you all
enjoyed your break I was grading your
papers during the break and it's like
well it's literally your job to uh you
gave us a paper due right you create the
curriculum like yeah you literally
scheduled this knowing that you would
have to spend your break grading papers
and it's like great we literally don't
care
we didn't ask you right and it's like
how long did grading papers take like if
it was a break like maybe you should
just work more efficiently and it
wouldn't take up your whole break no and
the comments were like oh great you
graded it well can you update like our
grade book so I can show my mom I'm not
failing anymore like come on get it
together other no like and can we have
our papers back because like right they
love to sit on them I don't think there
was a moment like more horrible in our
schooling than like the process of
handing back papers and tests like when
you would like he would walk around the
room or she and like Dole out everyone's
materials and then like he would fold
your corner down if you did really
poorly you know
um yeah I don't remember that moment oh
it's not Sierra like no I just yeah I
don't remember the process of them going
around and giving the test back also do
you remember like having when you were
much younger having to get your um
graded test time of course signed by a
parent of course but like that was abuse
but how does the teacher know what your
parents signature looks like oh for sure
I think and kids really do know what
their parent signature looks like so
yeah but they can't even they can't copy
it well but it doesn't matter they could
literally put a scribble and be like
yeah that's my parent signature like do
they have signature checks at the school
no I feel like they did like that's what
it felt like as a kid I think I feel
like they did too but that's really
extreme like no wonder you spent your
whole break like going over signatures
yeah no wonder why it took you so long
to grade the tests you were like doing
forgery like checks I feel like the
signature getting your parent to sign
your test isn't necessarily about making
sure the parent sees your bad grade it's
a also about like letting the kid know
that you [ __ ] up big like so big that
your parent has to sign the test and
like maybe everyone had to sign it maybe
that would be enough for the kid to like
work harder and if the grades keep going
down like then they call the parent
because like they could just call the
parent and be like your kids thinking up
the joint but I feel like a part of it
is like that kid accountability and
realizing that they are in a really bad
spot yes it's definitely the
accountability but didn't everyone have
to get their test signed not even if you
did poorly do you really have to get in
100 signed I wouldn't know
that was like a [ __ ] up partner trills
bro yeah bro that was just like a really
cool
you're extremely cool and hip I would
agree yeah no honestly no that wasn't
sarcasm coming for me oreo me neither
like you're extremely cool and hit
period yeah because my really cool
sister keeps me up to speed on
everything that's cool that's so nice of
you to say and she's really sweet her
name is Margo
wow I'm kidding I'm kidding she doesn't
tell me anything she doesn't talk to you
okay I spoke to her last night yeah
what big day it was a big day it was a
really really cool moment we had a nice
combo I'm so happy for you and you got a
whole weekend with her what was she like
it was fabulous it was fabulous you know
we're only a few years apart but like
there really are some serious
generational differences between Sinatra
and I one of them being the amount that
we're on our phone because I'm on my
phone so much like Margot cannot unplug
like we're all watching TV or just like
she's always on her phone
wow she can't unplug refusing to connect
with me like it's so annoying that's
really annoying that's definitely a pet
peeve of mine and I like I hate when
people are like get off your phone like
[ __ ] off like because I'm always on my
phone so for me to notice it and like be
annoyed by it it was really bad like
mid-conversation we were playing like
this really fun card game have you ever
played cheers governor
no oh my God it's so dumb it's like okay
see everyone in the group has to go
around and count one two three four five
six up until 21. but you have to
remember when you're counting that
number's 14 and 7 are swapped so it goes
one two three four five six fourteen
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
seven
and then when you get to 21 the person
who 21 lands on has to make up a rule so
it's like instead of saying one what we
did is like instead of saying 11 name
any Real Housewife of all time
so it would be like one two three four
five six fourteen eight nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen seven
you [ __ ] up oh [ __ ] Taylor Armstrong
seven and then you keep going until you
get all the numbers Armstrong 12 13 7
exactly exactly
so um I forgot where I was going with
the story oh counselor on her phone so
we were playing it's like really intense
and like you really need to focus
because if you don't remember everyone
has to start over like it's so annoying
and counts it's just like glued to her
phone I'm like who the [ __ ] are you
talking to I'm literally right here
right
who is she maybe I'm just maybe I'm just
not that interesting but I doubt that's
it
no I don't I don't think that's it me an
interesting no
but who is she talking to all day I
think she's just like you know an
influencer so there's like lots of
content she needs to consume engagement
I think she's preoccupied but I also
think it's a generational thing like
they're not even always doing something
you know yeah they're not always doing
so most of us aren't doing something on
our phones what's going to be your rule
when it comes to cell phones because the
concept of like raising kids like now is
so freaky to me like the the cell phones
social media like
what is your policy like we got flip
phones one like the fourth or fifth
grade yeah I feel like because of 9 11.
I'm gonna want to do something similar
to like what we had we got flip phones
in I think I got mine in the fifth grade
and so I want to get him a phone
whenever I do get him a phone like it's
not gonna be an iPhone it's gonna be a
phone that like makes calls and sends
texts hey if anybody needs to make a
call I've got a phone literally that I
think that they have like phones for
kids like that oh they should and then
there will be like iPad time where he
can go on YouTube and stuff oh I like to
do stuff that he wants to do are you
gonna Monitor and like mirror it as much
to what we experienced as possible even
though there is more technology now than
what we had
are you gonna monitor it like like what
he's doing or is that like an invasion
of privacy on the iPad I'm not gonna
monitor it but I'll definitely like go
in and see like what the searches have
been just like see what he's into if I
ever want to buy him a gift like I want
to know what tick tocker he likes you
know do you think that children are
entitled to privacy this is like a big
debate on Tick Tock like a lot of
parents
um it depends like in certain aspects
yes in other aspects no like if a kid is
writing in a diary I wouldn't read it
unless I was like really concerned about
what's going on with him and I couldn't
figure it out so I think it's Case by
case it's it's as you like to say it's
nuanced no I never say that I say it's
layered it's layered
so yeah no it's it just depends on
what's going on with the kid why what do
people on Tick Tock say you know people
are just going back and forth on like
parenting techniques like actually my
Bialik is going viral on Tick Tock I
don't know if you know this right now
it's so much Queen and it was actually
like a really interesting conversation
I'm sorry it's my indialic Lifetime
movie yes
that's one of my favorite stories I was
literally just about to bring it up but
I want to finish my point
like I just don't understand why she was
in a Christmas movie you know
okay you'll let us know later yeah well
so um
she has a podcast and a clip from her
podcast is going viral because she was
talking about this parenting technique
when like a kid falls and you say like
you're okay you're okay don't worry
you're okay you're in a sense like
invalidating this child's feelings
because like the child is to if you
asked you know Harry he's not okay but
you're like invalidating his feelings
being like you're fine
yeah I'm like well I did kind of
understand that I also thought about how
like when I would like [ __ ] and moan
like I was told I'm fine like I was
[ __ ] fine and I appreciated the
realness you know yeah no sometimes you
need someone to tell you like it's
nothing I feel like that's what we had
growing up like any time something
happened to be like it's nothing and
it's part of like the Freak Out is like
is something happened and like I'm
scared almost but if someone's there to
tell you like it's fine you are fine you
are okay it's like it's calming so sure
yeah if your kid's arm is broken and
dangling and you're saying like it's not
fine but if they trip and fall and like
they are okay I think it's good to let
them know that they're okay because like
it's a shock of course so then another
like a school of thinking came out that
I actually thought was
a good remedy was like when you say to
the kid like are you are you are you
hurt or are you just upset like identify
the feeling then I think we're just
getting like a little too much into the
feelings of a toddler we're getting so
into the weeds like by the way to a
toddler like hurt and upset are the same
thing they don't know the different
nuances between the two words
what parent is not busy enough to be
like are you hurt or are you upset what
parent when their kids say let's say you
like fall and scrape your knee in that
moment like you're as a parent too
you're like who and who's taking the
minute to be like heart or fat no by the
way the the line you just said about
like them not knowing the differences
literally so true
so true like your kids will be fine go
trust your gut if it's nothing let them
know it's nothing and if it's something
like let them know but I I don't think
it's like so you're not validating their
feelings but I think also I think that's
a major problem I think that too many
people's feelings have been validated
over the years and then when they're
confronted with something that they
don't like they're like wait why aren't
you validating my feelings and maybe
maybe it's because your feelings aren't
valid oh
oh puke Kobe
one of my favorite things to do is Kobe
like Kobe I can't watch anyone namely
Ben play basketball without being like
Kobe Kobe no same you wanna know
something really sweet yeah I was dming
you every time you were showing bed and
shooting hoops and I was saying Kobe and
do you know that the iPhone autocorrects
Kobe to love
why is that cute it's just like sweet
because no it's not no no because like
where the letters are they probably
think like k-o-b-e and l-o-v-e are like
right now that's right no no I don't
think that Apple did it like as an
homage to Kobe it's like a [ __ ] it's a
it's a coincidence that's really sweet
if anything it's disrespectful like them
not recognizing Kobe
but when they do recognize him they
recognize him as love but they're like
they're not I just thought it's not like
it's correcting Kobe to duck like
like I guess it's just a nice word okay
never mind no no I okay I'm sorry I
misunderstood I thought you were like
how cute that they did that no no not
that they did that but like that that's
what it autocorrects to like it's just
like a cute coincidence
yeah I just thought something funny but
it's like um
it's an offline story uh we need to
start a new podcast called the offline
stories because there's so much I want
to say like yesterday I found out the
craziest most hottest and it's so
annoying because I'm not gonna say it
but I found out the most insane thing
about an influencer like you'll never
hear a story so crazy in your life do
you agree because I told you it yeah
it's really crazy and I needed an
offline podcast where I could say it
like and not really sworn to secrecy
yeah you are sworn to secrecy I mean
like maybe in a few months it'll end up
on the patreon and I think that that's
fair
same it I hate to do with no names no
names
well it'll be fairly obvious I can't
talk about it like for real okay but
like part of me oh my God but you
brought it up and you keep bringing it
up yeah no because often when you find a
really good piece of Gossip you don't
want to not share it not because of the
person who the gossip is about but
because of the person who told you you
have to protect the messenger that's
really where it gets really complicated
with gossip and I actually was thinking
yesterday when it comes to gossip
um people who are like above gossip and
like all that what do you talk about
you well you know what they say
that it's like
um
uh what's the word
big people discuss ideas
small people discuss people
yeah something like that let me find the
exact quote that's like a really
obnoxious thing because like I I think
that like gossip is
really an exchange of information and it
makes the world go around and like I I
genuinely don't understand when people
like who vow not to gossip or like speak
ill of other people like what do you do
all day
you talk about ideas
okay I have an idea to gossip yeah let's
gossip
okay here are some quotes great minds
discuss ideas yeah this is it average
Minds discuss events small minds discuss
people yikes
I actually like just think that proverb
is [ __ ] I just want to say I feel
like we discuss a good mix of ideas
events in people and so we're just like
we what does that say about our minds no
and if you could boil anything down like
okay essentially people talking about
like politics are really gossiping
because like it's about people like
they're gossiping about senators and
stuff like it's gone yeah well it
depends what kind of politics but are
you talking about political Theory are
you talking about ideas for how to make
the world a better place not like who
should be in this person's not doing
that but like big Ideas I just think at
the end of the day gossip has gotten a
bad rap and it's really an exchange of
information
yeah I don't think an exchanging
information is Gossip I think putting
your
spin on it
oh I don't discuss it I don't do that
yeah no if you're
really getting all the facts right but
the problem is that the story that you
heard how do you know that that's all
the facts and in the way that it
happened so it inevitably already has
spin telephone and then you inevitably
put your spin on it because like that's
how people repeat stuff and memories as
stated are not perfect and the game
keeps going yeah
well one thing about me is I am gonna
gossip and that's just a little little
fact about me
okay can't wait to hear more hot gas
that's what we do here
you know what we do we do the fast five
stories and I think except for yesterday
except for yesterday oh my God you guys
deep apologies except not really because
you did not need to know the fifth Story
and so I think my subconscious was like
forget it because also I'll explain let
me talk about the first story why you
didn't need to know it
so without further Ado where Earth's
Trey's brother and nowhere to be found I
miss them dearly but I'm gonna like they
don't want to be here so what do you
want gonna do about it it is time for
the fast forward stories that you need
to know
and today's episode is sponsored by IHG
hotels and resorts the hotel company
made up of over 6 000 hotels and 17
amazing Brands they are taking care of
their guests this holiday season with
exclusive benefits like member discounts
a bonus points offer when downloading
the new ihg-1 rewards mobile app catalog
savings travel gear and more so IHG is
made up of really fabulous Brands like
Kimpton Hotels and restaurants
InterContinental Hotels and Resorts
Holiday Inn Express they have over 6 000
hotels and their all-new loyalty program
which is called ihg-1 rewards makes it
that much easier to check out and redeem
these campus offers right in the palm of
your hand with the new ihg-1 Rewards app
you can also download the app if you
haven't yet you'll start on earning
points with ease and redeem them for the
things that you want most you have to be
a member so don't wait to sign up I over
the last few years have really gotten
like my membership loyalty game on fleek
and I'm so excited about the new ihg-1
Rewards app I am of course already a
member
um
because they have such fabulous Brands
all over the world so whether you're
planning to travel for holiday or
whatever your Vibe is for me like I'm
very like beach luxury but everyone has
their own thing personally I'm gonna
drink a margarita on the beach
um an IHG hotels and resorts makes that
possible but whatever your Vibe is IHG
has got you covered for more details on
how to maximize your travels this
holiday season with IHG hotels and
resorts their cyber offerings if you
guys want to follow them you can do it
at ihg-1rewards on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter or visit ihg.com cyber sale
again you must be a member so don't wait
to sign up you can download the app or
just go to ihg.com cyber sale for all
the details on their new loyalty program
which is truly fabulous yes thank you so
much you're welcome
okay our first story today is the day
Spotify wrapped not only did everyone
get their year in review from Spotify
but Spotify also is sharing its most
streamed artists artists of the year and
songs of the year and podcasts and
podcasts yes our top five artists of the
Year from Spotify number one I'm not
gonna make you guess number one Bad
Bunny
number two Taylor Swift
number three the weekend sorry number
three Drake number four the weekend
number five BTS
that's not funny and BTS makes a lot of
sense because they're like really Global
artists
um I guess at this point Taylor Swift is
too and
when did she release red TV was that
this year too no
so it's kind of crazy because her album
came out a month ago
yeah that's really impressive it is
impressive also the most streamed songs
of 2022 number one song of the year
Harry Styles as it was number two is
heat Waves by glass animals and number
three this is crazy for the second year
running it's stay with Justin Bieber and
the kid Leroy
Apple's number one song of the year and
it's not even from this year
damn that's really impressive yeah
that's big numbers so last yesterday's
fifth Story was going to be apples your
end who cares data which I knew I didn't
realize Spotify rap was coming today but
I knew it was coming soon so we were
going to have a conversation about the
year in music and I only need to have
that conversation once really Spotify
and Spotify is the go-to for music so so
after that it's that time of year where
it's like horrendous to be an apple
music user and apple podcast user
because I mean we've been tagged this
morning already in like 500 people you
know of their top podcasts and stuff
like that so um something that I found
really interesting
is that you know when we first started
podcasting so everyone gets Spotify
wrapped but podcasters get their own
Spotify wrapped data on their listeners
where they're from categories genres
things like that I mean I imagine each
artist who's ever uploaded to Spotify
gets there right yes but people don't I
don't think realize podcasters get it
too yeah we get it too so um when we
first started podcasting we had actually
met with Spotify and they were just like
helping us they were really trying to
build up their podcasting platform we
had four percent of our listeners
listening on Spotify as of this morning
half of our listeners listen on Spotify
like half of our listeners have migrated
probably from Apple
two spots yeah and I just think that's
crazy it's crazy it means that the work
and the money that they're putting into
building out Spotify podcast is working
because we're not doing anything
different it's not it's really not a
reflection on us or our listeners
changing it's just them becoming a
bigger name in podcasting actually
though it's a little bit us because when
we promote on social media I now will
link out like when you do like a link
sticker I will link out to Spotify
because the way our podcast immediately
goes to Spotify and like takes like 30
minutes to get on Apple is so annoying
so because Spotify is just like doing
more they make it easier for us to
promote it that's so true yeah I feel
like people don't realize that sometimes
our podcast is not on Apple we only
upload it once and it goes to all of the
different places at the exact same time
and Spotify is there instantaneously and
apple is delayed all the time and for
everyone I always see people who have
podcasts being like it's not on Apple
yet don't know what to tell you so
Spotify is really just making it super
easy to listen
it's so annoying the way Apple like
doesn't I feel like Spotify like came
from the back and apple like never even
tried to compete they just like sit
there
yeah they're resting on their laurels
yeah but I guess it's because as Apple
like they make money off of every app in
the app store because like if you spend
money on an app like they take like 30
that's true but if you are listening to
podcasts through their podcasting app
that's like invaluable data
of course and I think that they sh would
probably want that data more but I feel
like they they're not taking other
competitors seriously and it shows like
I was just on the
podcast app I was looking for the charts
we're like charting in a major way these
days like on Apple yeah like in the
comedy section like we used to be like
well it's funny we were like 12 and then
we were eight like over time like steady
and now we're like holding firm at five
yeah we're five and six usually us
Heather McDonald the office girlies
morbid which I still don't understand is
what a comedy podcast and the yellow
um those three guys smart lists you know
I always like to predict who Spotify is
going to snatch up next and they just
snatched up anything goes with Emma
Chamberlain right we never even spoke
about that but I would have thought they
would have snatched up smartless
it's Jason Bateman Will Arnett and the
guy from um Will and Grace I'm sorry
don't come for me Sean Evans I think his
name is I don't watch Will and Grace
um but they're literally always number
one
yeah it reminds me so much of like
armchair expert like I it's the same
Vibe it's the same Vibe it's probably a
similar audience I feel like Spotify
needs to like take some of the news ones
that are um tops and kind of like
something outside of Comedy I feel like
they are really even Emma Chamberlain is
technically in the comedy category right
is she I don't think so oh okay well
what's interesting is they also release
their top podcast of the Year Joe Rogan
is number one obviously call her daddy
was number two and Emma Chamberlain is
number three even though her show wasn't
exclusive to Spotify and isn't even yet
so like she and I'm sure that's how they
made the decision to to go with her
acquire her right because Joe Rogan and
call her daddy being the top podcast on
Spotify like duh it's the only place you
can listen to that right right so that
makes a lot of logical sense but no her
podcast being third after when she's
available everywhere that must means I
mean her numbers are insane like
probably that's just huge
yeah huge and number four of top podcast
was uh case 63 which is uh starring
Julianne Moore and Oscar Isaac and
number five is crime Junkie
wow those crime junkie girlies really
kill it yeah also they have this really
sad category of top podcast called most
anticipated podcasts of the year which
means that it was based on their first
week streams for a newly released series
and then obviously it fell off after
that and number one is um archetypes yep
number of course there was so much hype
like The Duchess is gonna sit down and
podcasts with the people I know but I
just feel like they should have ignored
this category because it's just that
wait number two is Batman unburied never
heard of it number three is Kim
Kardashian's the system number four is
k-63 but I guess a lot of people listen
to the first episode and then they liked
it and they listened to more because
it's in the other category and then like
five oh number five is back to the beach
with Kristen and Steven but I feel like
that's surprising because I would I
didn't listen to the first episode I
listened to the last one I feel like
they probably grew during you could tell
by the way just based on like public
consumption like when they announced
back to the beach it was huge and there
was like 10 major stories that came out
of it it was like every time they
dropped an episode there was like a huge
PR like so many things everywhere
especially the last episode same with
like but also that's really impressive
because I think that's the only one on
the list that's not Spotify exclusive
yeah no that's huge for deer media yeah
but then like when you think about like
the pr Arc of Kim's podcast it's like it
was this big announcement and then it
was like a little controversy with the
victims families but then like nothing
that's how you know it like started big
because there was this big announcement
lots of press and then nothing was ever
picked up kind of assuming that the
numbers fell I feel like the same as
with archetypes like of course everyone
was quaking when the first episode came
out but then I don't think it was what a
lot of people expected it was very um
like not scripted produce thank you
um and I remember like the first two
episodes it was like let's like there
was so much uh press about it and now I
just saw one thing about the final
episode it's like Andy Cohen's on and
there's not even like a lot of fanfare
for it
yeah I also I think that's a pattern
with celebrity podcasts in general not
just Spotify where it's like oh great if
you're a celebrity launch a podcast your
first episode's gonna be pretty big
because people want to hear what you
have to say and they're fans of you to
begin with but to commit someone to a
podcast listener like you are taking a
minimum an hour out of the week like to
sit and listen to something for an hour
like you need to be so entertained
you're not doing it as a favor to the
celebrity that you like and follow
because also like you're listening
privately aside from Spotify rap you
don't share what you listen to It's not
like a virtue signal to be like hey I
listened to a big fan yeah I know that's
so true like it's easy to get people to
listen to a famous person's podcast the
first few weeks but like podcasts are
really
um just judged by Merit like what are
they good and it's an intimate person
that doesn't mean you're good it's an
intimate thing and it's a private thing
you're right about celebrity podcasts
and that's why like you know Conan and
smartless are so successful because not
only are they actually famous but their
podcasts are actually good yes even
though never listened to it but no but
the charts speak the charts don't lie I
don't think
I don't know I don't think they lie are
editorialized but sometimes they think
that they are well I feel like the
Spotify ones might be a little
editorialized because like they spend
100 million on Joe Rogan I mean I do
think Joe Rogan is actually number one
but like if I was Spotify in like Joe
Rogan's episode like flopped I would
still put him in like the top three just
to like one give it more press people
are checking the charts and two like you
don't want to admit like your investment
maybe was bad even though I think Joe
Rogan's a bad example because he's
literally one two five armchair expert
any all the other Investments other than
Joe Rogan yes I think it behooves them
to lift them up give them a little
right
um also because that's how people
discover podcasts they go to the top
charts they say I wonder if this is the
number one show number two show
something that like looks good and so it
would be who of them to have the top
shows looking good that are their shows
you know what now that I think about it
like when Joe Rogan went to Spotify
there was like so much hooplan fanfare
and and he's had like controversies and
stuff I feel like he's always very
current like him being number one makes
sense same with Al super like her
episodes depending on guests like are
huge historic cultural moments now that
I think about it like armchair expert
like is kind of like
where is armchair expert I don't ever
hear anything about armchair expert me
neither but I also don't listen for
armchair I don't like it's I think it
would come up in our stories he's he
interviews famous people no no I mean
yes he interviews famous people but even
when he was on Apple we never really
talked that much about what he was doing
because he has like conversations with
like no one's really it's not like a
t-spilling like thing it's conversations
with people
like he interviews all these people but
it's not really like they make
buzzworthy headlines because he's just
like getting to know people and talking
to people they're not there to like drop
something yeah okay this is I feel like
what people go on call her daddy to do
to drop something yeah yeah that's true
that's true
um I'm in the top podcast did they
change their artwork armchair experts I
don't see it
I'm telling you I'm a little oh it's
number 12. oh that's good
anyways
that's the podcasting news and I feel
like now that Spotify is really bummed
up aside from their Spotify Originals
like it is really a good place to see
but you can't really compare like
I wish Apple would drop Spotify I mean
um podcast information but then the
shows that aren't on Spotify like in
order to be the best you have to beat
the best but I feel like the best and
the best aren't even competing anymore
right no and that's what's so
interesting to me about podcasting in
general is like it is this kind of
mystery because you know you're
following YouTubers you can see how many
subscribers they have podcast numbers
are all behind some sort of like
dashboard and everyone you know on
social media is like out here making
look like their podcast look like the
baddest and the best and just because
I'm like nosy I'm always curious like
who actually gets a lot of downloads and
like who doesn't and you can tell but
like I would love like a little bit more
transparency in that department
yeah
that's just crazy it's a mystery yeah
but you know what maybe it's better
because I feel like people put their
Heart and souls into podcasts and if it
was really measured by like listeners
and that was so public like I feel like
it would be a little disheartening as
opposed to starting a slow grind and
it's not like YouTube where it's so
instantaneous and if this video didn't
work like let's do it in this video like
you really have to build up and I feel
like if it was
more uh competitive it might deter
people and people might like be having
conversations just so they get those
numbers that those people are getting
and I feel like this makes it a little
more real and no that's actually really
um I agree now you change my mind
you're right it is so personal and
people put like so much of their heart
and soul into it yeah and I wouldn't
want someone to think like say they did
one episode that was like really
personal intimate and like actually good
but they just like didn't get a lot of
listeners for whatever reason like I
wouldn't want that podcaster and people
knew that like I wouldn't want that
podcaster to then be like well I'm never
gonna do that again because it didn't
work like right it's not charges with
podcasts and also sometimes the episodes
that like get the most listens like I
don't know what it is we've talked about
we were just talking about this well you
know with our Spotify download you know
what our most listened to episode of the
year was
you I just found out this morning and I
never would have guessed right because I
am yeah Bridge to Terabithia which was a
hilarious episode which also featured
our interview with Jessica Knoll and I
just I I never would have guessed that
I never would have guessed that either
you know what I think that it was like
this is how I think of it I think it was
the end of a week episode
before a long weekend because I remember
I came to New York right after that so
maybe there was like a few days without
episodes so everyone listened to the
most recent one but we had longer breaks
and I I just I don't know and I think
Jessica Knoll is also like really Niche
yeah and
a whole different community of listeners
who wanted to tune in for her interview
oh yeah like we got new listeners it's
outside actually what I thought was also
really interesting that Spotify did was
they'll tell you which episodes like
featuring guests share that things that
you that you sent me okay hold on they
they said they give you like a little
wrap for your whole podcast it's like 10
slides of data and it was fascinating
stuff this was interesting we created 10
000 minutes of new content and that is
more than 99 of other creators in the
comedy category
sure
um
yeah
bridge to ter Bridget to Terabithia was
our most listened to episode our top
five countries are U.S Canada the UK
Australia and Ireland
our country Irish toasters our podcast
was in the top one percent of most
shared episodes like people either
texting sending a direct link sending on
Instagram WhatsApp which I thought was
really interesting yeah WhatsApp was
small
okay so this episode attracted a lot of
new listeners
so three percent of people three percent
of our audience started listening with
this episode so interesting Sophia
yanklin with Sophia Franklin
yeah now we did get a lot of press from
that episode because she was talking
about the call her daddy drama so like
maybe that was it I thought that was
that was a really good piece of data
yeah
um and the rest of these were like you
know kind of boring we're in the top one
percent of most followed podcasts look
at us
that makes sense there's so many
podcasts but what's so interesting and I
think it's just what makes Spotify so
smart for doing this obviously is like
people love it so like they're ever I
cannot keep up with how many people are
tagging me in their stories but Spotify
is also now becoming like a major data
company and that's how you make all the
money in Tech like having people's data
and they every year they're just like a
crewing the [ __ ] out of everyone's datas
it's so smart but they also present it
in a way that we love like if you tell
me you're selling my data I'm like
goodbye I'm deleting your app right if
you tell me I'm gonna learn something
about myself or my data and it'll be in
these like shareable snackable cards I
could post to my Instagram click
subscribe that's so true
um and I also while we're talking about
wrapped I want to hear your Spotify
wrapped oh it was very predictable
um what were your top five songs and who
were your top five artists my top five
artists were ER
okay top artist Taylor Swift Luke Combs
John Mayer Morgan Wallen Kelsea
ballerini so it's like very country
yeah what was your top genre
pop which is the same weird not
everything's pop yeah
what were your top songs okay so number
one was 100 by
is that because of your shows
no
oh you just really were listening to
yourself on me I honestly don't even
remember listening to it that much which
is like kind of crazy do you think that
maybe like you put it on repeat one song
like when it launched to like
and it doesn't sound like you I know I'm
not like desperate like that I mean I am
but like but not like that no not if it
means you have to listen to your song
over and over again right number two
doing this Luke Combs three heart first
Kelsey ballerini for tomorrow Me by Luke
Combs and five she's in love with the
boy by Trisha Yearwood a 90s classic
gorgeous
and then artists I told you already yeah
what about you
top artists number one Luke Combs I
think I'm Luke combs's biggest fan ever
more than any of the other sisters
because he was my number one artist and
he's four out of my five top songs wow
my number two artist was Frederick
Chopin that's um and otahari we listen
to a lot of classical music but I had no
idea that I was listening to Chopin so
much exclusively so much more than
Ludwig or
Mozart like yeah that who's Amadeus
Mozart okay yeah or Ludwig van Beethoven
honestly that was a shock for me three
Taylor Swift for Morgan Wallen five Mimi
Webb
cute
then my top songs were one tomorrow me
two middle of somewhere my favorite song
three the kind of love we make four want
that back by Brett Eldridge gorgeous
song check it out five doing this Luke
such a Luke girly I'm such I'm a bigger
Luke Combs fan than snatcher alert
though let's naturally hear that well
she's gonna see the date and she's gonna
know for herself my favorite thing about
Spotify rap we talk about this every
year is when people are like that that
seems right it's like no no it's
literally facts it's correct no it's
your data so it should feel right no
it's so it is right
Jackie I literally
I did that you posted that to your story
about it as like a ironic no
no I was like no this feels right
oh my God you were making fun of me
I thought you did that ironically
because we always say that and I think I
remember that that we said that honestly
this is how delusional I am I thought it
was like an Ode to the redheads because
we always say that when we finish the
rating for the book that's whatever no
that's totally everyone gives a rating
and then I do the average and every
single time you have snitch that feels
right
um no that's really why I did it
actually I was not making fun of you to
your face no no you didn't know that you
were like making fun of me because I
actually used that caption completely
unironically and it just genuinely felt
right
because it was right what do you know
what do you know okay are you ready for
our next story if it's the next story
that's brought to you by Legacy box
the best gift for you or your family
it's what Better Homes and Gardens
called the most sentimental gift to make
this holiday season special plus with
their Cyber Monday event more families
can reclaim Priceless footage with an
insane 65 off so Legacy box is a simple
and safe way to digitize your treasured
videotapes film reels photos and they've
helped over a million families even
hours do just that everything is done by
hand right here in the US they'll
convert your media to digital copies and
then they'll always be protected from
floods mold even the decay of time so
this is probably the sponsor I get the
most questions about especially now with
holiday season roll around like over the
weekend five people wrote in toast after
dark what is the Legacy box code so
Legacy box is digitizing by hand all of
your old memories we grew up in the VHS
age but whether you have like cassettes
camcorders I don't know whatever you got
Legacy box can do it
their cyber week event is here they are
giving our listeners the best deal of
the year so visit legacybox.com toast to
save an unreal 65 off this is an amazing
gift you obviously can gift it to
someone and they don't have to send it
out immediately they can hang on to it
you know go into storage in a few months
get all their old VHS out of storage but
you have the box you can get the offer
right now so you'll save the money give
it to the person and then they can do it
whenever they want it comes with a label
it's so easy and then you get emails
along the way updating you of like
what's going on like it just arrived
we're doing this I think I got like
total 12 emails when I do it so like it
feels like you're literally handing over
a piece of your heart you want to make
sure that like it's not lost they are
always keeping you updated on the
progress and the process of what they're
doing so with limited quantities that
are ready to ship this deal will go fast
legacybox.com toast for 65 off
legacybox.com toast today's episode is
also brought to you by Bruce an electric
toothbrush that will change the way you
think about brushing your teeth with
powerful Sonic technology and Ultra
Dental bristles the brush redefines what
it means to have super clean teeth it's
like that feeling when you just leave
the dentist it's a fresh whole mouth
clean but every single day get 20 off
when you pick up your brush kit and the
plan at brush.com toast so when you get
the brush kit it includes the electric
toothbrush three brush heads a magnetic
charging station a Sleek travel case and
what I love most about it is that the
battery life lasts four weeks so if you
don't want to have a charger on your
countertop you can just leave the
charger in your cabinet and then like it
looks really Sleek if you're traveling
you don't have to like bring your
charger with you unless you're traveling
for more than a month in which case I'm
very jealous so it can last an entire 30
days on a full charge it's perfect for
traveling and a countertop being charger
cord free
it's a fabulous toothbrush it's a
fabulous stocking stuffer it's also a
really affordable electric toothbrush a
lot of the toothbrushes out there like
cost insane amounts but when you go to
brush.com toast
b-r-u-u-s-h.com slash toast you will get
20 off when you pick up the brush brush
kit and the plan at brush.com toast
b-r-u-u-s-h.com get the toothbrush that
is industry leading uses Sonic
technology and produces 42 000 brush
Strokes per minute which is 300 times
300 brush Strokes per minute it helps
with deep cleaning hard to reach places
the gums the tongue the molars brush.com
toast
thank you mclartia
we are welcome
our next Story another little year-end
review moment People magazine has put
forth their people of the year
the four celebs who were here to help in
2022
so let me guess what is the concept
people honors four people for the
inspiring work they did this year would
it be helpful if I shared last year's
people of the year yeah because are
these like philanthropists
yeah philanthropist activists like
good good doing celebrities okay here's
last year
Dolly Parton Simone biles Sandra o and
America's teachers
okay and the year before was George
Clooney Dr fauci Selena Gomez and Regina
King so it's like um so who did a lot
this year
who what who did a lot this year I feel
like Harry Styles did a lot but not from
like a
philanthropy or like activisms you know
he just like was working a lot
yeah no it's not about everything he's
an artist okay right Matthew McConaughey
kinta Brown yeah
oh yeah
Mila Kunis
yeah and Jennifer Hudson
yeah okay those are pretty good mm-hmm
it does feel like you know all of them
were out there doing the most
trying their best yeah did you hear
anything about the new j-hud show
no this was actually in this article was
like the first I heard about it since we
talked about that she was getting a show
yeah I haven't heard much about it is it
not on cable I think it's on peacock
really
because I just saw because I followed
Jamila Jamil on Instagram she went on
and she was like going on peacock TV and
it was like j-hud oh interesting so I
just want to Google that because I was
so confused like
won an egot this year
so for that reason alone
she should be people of the year but she
also um
as a very Mission oriented talk show
she's also she's on cable I apologize
but um I believe she's also probably
being promoted hard on tick on uh
peacock I almost said Tick Tock yeah
tick tock
you know I feel like People magazine is
like constantly putting together lists
it's like the one thing keeping their
business afloat they're making a list
and checking it twice to take the doors
down
they're literally taking the doors down
this is the time of year where we get
lists Galore I personally really like
them I love to see my here in list form
we do something for
um December patreon episodes top this
top that
um so I just I like to ingest see what
other people think are tops of the year
I just I don't know why I don't know why
Kelly Clarkson doesn't make these lists
to me they're like rooted in error
because of that I do also like like at
the end of the year means we get a lot
of lists and we get to look at our year
at a glance but some of the lists feel
stupid and this is one of them
do you agree
I agree like they said a whole bunch of
nothing about what they're even saying
about these people like what they're
saying about these people is that here's
the quote the boldest thing that we can
do question mark help
I've been thinking a lot about what
inspires someone to take action to
donate their time and money and passion
to a cause to do anything more than fire
off a tweet or an Instagram post it's
been on my mind become because the world
seems to need our help more than ever
and also because the people we celebrate
in this issue didn't hesitate to meet
the moment they didn't ask why me or
wait for permission or get caught up in
self-doubt they just moved
okay like that's a pretty decent
description because you know
um
Matthew McConaughey and Uvaldi and
Ukraine for Mila Kunis like I get it
I just feel like this list is dumb I
can't explain why
like you know what I mean yeah
especially when you like look back at
past winners it's not like no also
because when you think of lists from
People magazine like you think of most
beautiful and it's like stick to the
dumb [ __ ] you know but they're clearly
wanting to be like a list where you can
find the outsides and the insides yeah
they want to be beautiful on the outside
and the inside I appreciate that but
like for me People magazine like is an
airport tabloid like it will always I
will never read a People magazine if I'm
not on an airplane yeah I agree stick to
the superficial lists and and the freak
Show circus greatest showman stories
about you know cousins who married
cousins and I want a list about the
craziest stories of the Year yes that's
what people magazine like 10 of the
biggest freak shows of 2022.
no I won't just people's biggest freak
Show you decided yes number one put them
on the cover yeah yeah I like that like
the wildest stories of 2022 because
they'll find it you know family locked
up in Chains
yeah for 35 years like they'll always
find terrible stories like that yeah I
there was one recently
um I don't know if I read it in people
but about the 30-year embryos
what's that
this couple
um
adopted embryos because a lot of embryos
that aren't used just like stay frozen
but people can adopt an embryo and then
carry it and give birth to an embryo so
this couple intentionally
adopted the oldest embryo availability
yeah they adopted the oldest embryo
available because like they wanted to
give this oh it's an adoption it's I
don't know if that's the correct word
but that's essentially what it is like
you adopt the embryo and then you carry
it yourself interesting so they
intentionally uh adopted the oldest
embryo so that you know that embryo
could come off the shelf and the embryo
is technically 30 years old so these are
like 30 year old babies
well that's a very hot take if you know
life starts at conception but I know
what you're saying like
um wait why would the couple go for
wouldn't you want like the freshest one
like you want the best yes no but that's
the thing like most people go for the
freshest one so this couple like wanted
to give like the oldest embryo that
would probably never come off the shelf
like a chance at life
that was very sure it's very weird this
story is very weird because like no
that's that's what I'm saying it's
frozen they're all the same age no and
they're embryos they're not 30 year olds
no they're not 30 year olds but
technically like they've been what so
the kid comes out with like a receding
hairline they're babies they are babies
but like they were technically created
30 years ago so it was just like 30 year
old babies was the headline to make it
sound [ __ ] crazy oh because People
magazine was clickbaiting us got it okay
understood right but like if you if you
make your own embryos and like they were
technically Frozen two years ago like
you don't say I have a two-year-old of
course not that's the idea that they
were frozen 30 years ago like makes it
you know a crazy headline which it is
crazy I just want to say like the
concept when people go into adoption
like they say like the newborns like
they always get adopted and then that's
how kids end up like 12 13 in the system
so to adopt a 12 or 13 year old is such
an admirable thing to do I don't think
the same applies to embryos like those
people should have just taken the
freshest one okay
no but that's the same concept to them
of like everyone's going for the
freshest ones uh we're not worried about
them they will get I get it but I'm
telling these people it's not the same
like like they're looking at it through
the lens of like adoption it's not the
same
but otherwise those embryos would have
never come off the shelf
no I understand that I'm just now
learning that embryos can be adopted
like this is huge for me I guess like it
totally makes sense like I just
literally never thought of that because
a lot of people create embryos that I
mean we see that they don't end up using
that they don't end up using and we saw
it like with celebrities what happens to
the embryos that's okay Jackie literally
I was just gonna say I can't think of
embryos without thinking of that
terrible story about what happened to
Sofia Vergara and her evil ex-husband
right so if they don't like make the
decision to
discard the embryos they they stay
frozen and they sit there and people
could then adopt them no it's nice I
never thought about it but it makes
sense yeah I send you the article you
should have read it there was a lot of
interesting stuff in there yeah I did
hmm
gotta catch up on my reading like like
it's not something where you just read
the headline like keep reading it's it's
wild oh yeah you would think you went
through a weird bout where you were
sending like really [ __ ] weird
articles to me about like like baby
stuff like this mom found her baby's
diaper full of blood what happened next
what happens next is unexpected
that was the craziest story it was a
crazy story it was a story
yeah this early founder baby her baby
girl's diaper was full of blood maybe
she was one years old she wasn't like a
newborn but she was still in diapers and
so she took her to the hospital like she
was freaking out and turned out that the
girl had her first period She had like
early onset menstruation which is a
thing that like happens it's extremely
rare it was like early onset puberty yes
and I guess when it happens like you end
up in the New York Post so I did read
that article and that's why I didn't
read the next article you sent which was
about the 30 year old babies because I'm
like this girl is trying to freak me out
like but you didn't find like that
didn't make you want to read like more
crazy articles not really because like I
just feel like I could have lived
without knowing that like there is a
condition where like you can be getting
your period and pubic hair and breasts
at two years old like I could have lived
without knowing that but now I had to
share it on the podcast and now everyone
knows and now we've said it okay also I
think it's worth saying the 30 year old
baby embryos I believe they're twins
or their genetic siblings and like two
embryos weren't planted but there was
two of them
not just one two
so check it out for yourself
interesting reading coming from Jackie
you should work for People magazine yeah
I could like vet what's interesting
enough yeah what's wacky enough
wacky enough for Jackie
that'll be like the name of your column
wacky Jackie oh my God you guys should
give me a call on People magazine after
how we just slandered you to fill well
that was like when I remember growing up
there was a column in the New York Post
called weird but true and it was like
the weirdest crimes that went on in the
city that week and it really was like
always crazy yeah they're still that's
they still have that column it's a good
one mm-hmm
are you ready for our next story we've
got to move on we've gotta
um oh my God we've got it because we
still have your toasters I know I know
okay our next story is Netflix has a new
streaming giant show that has overtaken
stranger things weddings of minutes have
been streamed it is the new Smash Hit
Wednesday
becomes a Smash Hit for Netflix as it
Dethrone stranger things and breaks the
streaming Giants viewership you know
what good those stranger things kids
needed to be humbled yeah for sure Tim
Burton's Wednesday has become a Smash
Hit for Netflix and it's debut week on
the streaming giant the show with shars
Jenna Ortega is the main character
Christina Ritchie and Catherine
Zeta-Jones racked up a record meeting
making
341.2 million viewing hours whatever the
[ __ ] that means and beat stranger things
according to Netflix it is also the
number one show in 83 countries tying
with stranger things
I mean it's kind of a brilliant concept
one because it's Tim Burton and people
like really love and admire and follow
his work two it's like the cult fam fan
favorite of The Adams Family but totally
reimagined but with the original
Wednesday Adams playing someone else and
with Catherine Zeta Jones I think she
played the mom Morticia yeah she's
playing someone else too so it's like it
has elements and it's like nods to the
original show but with a whole new
concept I think it's like a really
really well done I don't want to say
reboot but like reimagination it's a
very smart idea I'm not personally into
Adam's family or like spooky shows like
I don't watch stranger things but I get
why this is so big it's actually
surprising to me that it's so big
because I feel like for all the reasons
that you described like it would be
really good and really well received
like and critically acclaimed but when I
think of like Tim Burton and I think of
The Adams Family definitely huge devoted
audiences but also kind of Niche so to
know that like that audience is the
biggest audience on Netflix that to me
is surprising I'm here for it I'm happy
for all of the
Burton toasters and Adam's stands I just
am surprised to know that it's really
that big of numbers well also if you
think about it like it's really bridging
like a generational Gap because people
who loved The Adams Family are much
older now and Jenna Ortega is like this
everything of the sort stunning like
Instagram girly
um so it's really got something for
everyone and you love when there's
something for everyone I do but you know
what the Adams Family makes me think of
this is how I know if we'll have if we
have the same brain
you've already we've had this
conversation I know what you're going to
say
there's Olivia and Marco Claudia and
Jackie they're all a little wacky the
ashrae family
that looks like a little jingle they
made up in Camp about us it was pretty
cool
how added to the list of stories since I
literally knew what you were gonna say
no I really don't say that one as much
as I should and like am I becoming that
girl who like peaked at camp like all I
do is talk about camp like it's like
embarrassing no I don't think that means
that you peaked at camp
no
do you think you've peaked yet
in I think they're like diff like in
certain Realms yes but in other Realms
no
like I think I I think I've maybe have
peaked in looks
I know you haven't no you haven't but
yeah
I feel like I've not necessarily like
even peaked in like
fulfillment and happiness but let me
tell you why I don't think you've peaked
in looks because your breast reduction
is ahead of you and it's over for
everyone when that happens that's so
true yeah everyone like you better hide
out hide your kids hide your wife yeah
no but so I just feel like there's more
waiting for me that like I didn't ex
like that I haven't experienced yet and
I will peek in those areas like other in
or even I'm peaking in those areas now
um but in other Realms like in certain
areas my best days might be behind me
that's okay yeah what about you
do you think you're peeking I think
viral on Tick Tock you're like so
slender you have two hits I don't wanna
um honestly like I don't want to say it
you know like Jinx like I just feel like
I'm like kind of like in like my like my
era right now like I really don't want
to jinx it I understand that you don't
want to jinx it but it's like if you
don't recognize that you're if you don't
realize it personally okay but like so
for everyone out there like if you don't
realize in your best ERA that this is
your best ERA like you stand the chance
of like missing it no I'm fully
acknowledged it I think like my physical
peak is like is like two months ahead of
me like I'm really I've gotten so good
on like my journey and my makeup and my
hair like I feel like it's and I had
like major weight loss a few years ago
but I was like so bad at my makeup and
like so dumb and young like I wasn't
able to really maximize the weight loss
and now I just feel like I'm much more
mature I'm much more refined and I just
feel like my physical peak like it's
happening especially now that I'm really
thinking about my breast reduction like
once that happens like you're you can't
get rid of me [ __ ] like I will be in
bikini photos like taking pictures all
over this country but then do you also
feel like so you're having this physical
peak which you've looked great at other
times before so it's not necessarily
anything new but you're also like a
viral tick tocker everyone's talking
about you like you're the voice of your
generation your podcast is now number
five maybe in the last weight loss like
it was number 15. no and I think we
would be remiss to not acknowledge like
how this has really been a great year
for our business like we're very very
lucky and very blessed
um of course you know Tick Tock is
everything but you know the podcast and
just like businesses is going good we
should acknowledge that because you know
there's been many times part of this
business is Peaks and valleys Peaks and
valleys and there have been many valleys
over the last few years so we have to
acknowledge the Peaks and this has
really been a great year and we couldn't
have done it without the toasters
so true so I think I wake up every day
and I think the toaster is like for
for believing in us and for enjoying the
show and enjoying our certain special
brand of humor our certain special brand
of humor and just like forgetting us
for understanding us not forgetting us
for space getting space us yeah please
don't forget us that's literally my
worst nightmare
um what were we talking about peaking so
if you're out there and you've peaked
you know what pressure's off what was
the story if you're currently peeking
enjoy it and if it's ahead of you
anticipate it yeah it's all good
what was the story how did we start
talking about this Wednesday Adams
Peaks at camp
got it okay thank you for the for the
retraction retracing
our next story is about one of Claudia's
favorite people and it's about probably
his favorite people
that's really confusing
Brendan Frazier hits the red carpet with
his two handsome Sons Holden 18 and
Leland 16 so just note the ages before
you say anything crazy at the whale
screening in New York City the [ __ ]
would I say no I don't know like like
116 like they're like
um
they're made in the image of Brendan but
like they're oh are they really hot
they're they're nice looking boys yeah
okay so what did you I'm so confused
what you thought I was gonna say like
something mean no no no like something
inappropriate yeah got it okay but
they're minors thank you for the heads
up I understand I must look up a picture
of these children yeah uh Leland and
Holden uh the 53 year old actor hit the
red carpet with his handsome sons in a
New York City screening of the whale the
teens look just like their famous dad
when he was a young Hollywood pinup in
films like Encino Man and George of the
Jungle they really they look different
from one another but they both look like
Brendan and
it's really sweet family moment I don't
know why I can't find this picture what
Daily Mail Daily Mail here here
yeah Daily Mail was oh wow
they're extremely like handsome are they
models they have like that model look I
mean they're I think they're still in
school who knows what they're gonna do
but I feel like they could go into the
industry if they so choose they're
probably mad I'm like I can't help but
honestly get like like teary-eyed they
must be so proud of their dad oh man I'm
literally gonna cry
they must be because they like weren't
alive for his Heyday and they probably
have just really experienced some of the
hard few years that he went through and
now to like be in New York City
screening his movie that's like gonna be
nominated for an Oscar gonna be
nominated for everything and their dad
is the man of the hour like I'm sure
it's a big moment
um and he was there with his girlfriend
his longtime partner yeah I think she's
a makeup artist her name is
but she is not the parent the mom excuse
me Jen Gian Moore oh I don't know if
she's the yeah that's no Afton Smith is
the parent got it that's interesting I
want to know who that is
Afton Smith yeah
wow that is so cute I love I need to see
this movie I know and did you keep
scrolling for the pictures of Brendan
and Sadie sink
no oh my God they're so cute I literally
like I'm obsessed with that friendship
obsessed we need to see this movie
mclared I know
like we need to plan a date night is it
out yet
who knows it's probably coming out
around the holidays add it to your list
with crawdads I do think it's a very um
like sad and depressing movie so just
trigger warning
true and I hope no dogs die I will be so
upset
you for bringing it back to that
are you ready for our fifth and final
story little light-hearted news sure
real houses of Miami taglines are here
oh and they're pretty good okay first up
we have Alexia she says quote in Miami
the sun brings the heat but I bring the
fire Q strong Larsa
my favorite she said hate all you want
because if I were you I'd hate me too oh
[ __ ] nasty like if I were you I'd
hate me too yeah jealous wench that's
all that's missing at the bottom if I
knew I'd hate me too wench you jealous
wench
next Gertie the only thing that moves
faster than my mouth is my ambition
it's not great because like while I
admire your ambition it's really
admirable like it's not really pertinent
to this show no and the first half is
strong because her mouth says but then
it's like giving like it's like we're on
peacock this is a different era like
everyone has leveled up and it's just
like giving old Housewives like the only
thing about me is me yeah no so true
like Real Housewives of Miami definitely
stands out it's like a much better like
highly produced younger fresher version
of how size and this is giving very much
like you know in this town
you know yeah yeah
then we have Julia she said when the
chicks fly The Coop it's time for this
mama bird to spread her wings
it's okay it's good because she's the
farm girl and her girl and now she's uh
spreading her wings I actually I think
that it is it's not what I would want
for mine
but it's it's it's it's apt next the
most interesting cast member of the
Season Lisa hochstein
you can try to take my castle but you
will never steal my crown
so is she losing her castle Yeah because
like she's divorcing I know
um and so I feel like she's like talking
to Lenny you know you can try and take
the [ __ ] but he's not trying to steal
her crown like I feel like it should be
like you could try to take my castle but
I'll always have my crown yeah yeah no I
agree like conceptually it's good
execution-wise it needed like a few
tweaks it's fine I do think this will be
incredibly interesting to watch their
divorce is like so messy bad yeah I feel
it's like really sad did she sign a
prenup I remember they spoke about it
last season
I don't know I feel like she probably
did I feel like she didn't
or actually I know it was disgusting I
can't remember
um
anyways um if they want to Tinker it to
what I suggested before the show airs
we'll pretend like we didn't see this
free idea and then your favorite
housewife Dr Nicole Martin uh what
happens Marisol she's still friend of
she might be an and uh Adriana's not fit
well Adriana and Marisol were both
friend of I would have thought after the
season Adriana would be asked to leave
permanently and Marisol would have been
a full-time housewife even though I
think she doesn't want to be yeah well
Dr Nicole said I'm a pro at The Rules of
Engagement and I have the ring to prove
it
I like wouldn't really Flex about that
because there was so much weirdness
around her engagement how she spent the
whole season being like we're so happy
not engaged we're so happy
and then she got engaged yeah I wouldn't
Flex about it just because like it's not
like you were like trying for a ring
this whole time and now you got it like
it the way they pretended like it's like
you didn't even notice that your needs
are not engaged
totally well real house is Miami
actually is very good and even though
I've been kind of on like a Housewives
break I will definitely be watching
because peacock is easy 100 I'm totally
gonna watch and it's really a very good
franchise and I like a lot of the ladies
like a lot yeah no I have to be watching
for my girl Larsa and Lisa
Lisa for me I'm like Alexia and Marisol
till I die I know you really are I like
maybe it's like a Nostalgia from the old
show
um because I was really like obsessed
with Alexia back then and Mama Elsa I
don't know why it's not even because I
think they're necessarily like always
you know on the right side or they're
the most fabulous I love their
friendship I love that they're like oh
geez who are still bringing it and like
they're still fabulous I just really
like them
good I like that for you
so those were the past five but do not
fret because today's episode is far from
over because we've got deer toasters
it's Wednesday Our advice segment deer
toasters is every Wednesday and you can
be featured you know if you have a
problem that something you're going
through email us deertoesters gmail.com
will of course keep your name out of it
it's totally Anonymous you can change
people's names just to you know protect
the privacy of those involved but we've
got three great submissions today and
they're brought to you by diff eyewear
so diff eyewear sunnies are pulling
double duty when I wake up and I'm not
feeling Flawless my oversized trendy
sunglasses from diff eyewear can handle
the little in-between moments in life we
all know that oversized sunnies are
super Glam and they can make every
outfit outfit really feel like a Chic
fashion moment but personally I love
them because they transcend fashion they
become an actual functional need for me
they look fabulous to hide my eyes when
I'm hungover if I have a puffy face or
I'm just like not feeling the paparazzi
that day there's so many Chic oversized
diff Shades like the edgy Goldies or the
Glam Becky twos that really get the job
done they're basically The Hangover
Shades because after too much fun on a
Saturday night out heading to that
brunch the next day you're feeling the
red puffy eyes you've got a little bit
of light sensitivity bam throw on a pair
of oversized diff sunnies and you'll
instantly look put together hangover
gone I also just got a bunch of new
sunnies for my trip to Belize the end of
this month and I generally steer towards
like oversized glasses I'm always online
looking for like huge Kardashian Vibe
like Kris Jenner really has really good
ones and they're like a million dollars
diff has great options they're super
affordable tons of different colors
different Vibes more trendy more classic
oversight studies can rescue you if you
want to save face and make your outfit a
little bit more Fab so again the
oversized trendy shades are handling
those moments where you don't feel like
showing your face but you gotta right
now you can score a sweet deal for the
holidays diff is offering an amazing 50
off plus visit
eyewear.com chose for a chance to win a
thousand dollars cash and score your own
diff sunnies for a year or diff um
the oversized settings for an entire
year or the thousand dollars cash excuse
me so that's diff eyewear.com toaster
having a huge sale amazing 50 off
but they're also doing a chance to win a
thousand dollars cash and score your own
diff sunnies for a year today's episode
is also brought to you by modern
fertility think back to sex ed for a
moment you probably learned all about
how to prevent pregnancy but did you
ever learn about how to plan for it
that's why modern fertility was created
an easy and affordable way to test your
fertility hormones at home with a simple
finger prick mail it in with a prepaid
label and you'll get your personalized
results within six days you'll get
insights into your hormone levels like
your ovarian reserve other important
factors that you can that can impact
your fertility as well the results go
deep into what every hormone means and
you can also download the results to
review with your doctor for next steps
traditional hormone testing at a
fertility clinic can cost over six
hundred dollars but modern fertility
tests the same general set of hormones
at a fraction of the price and if you go
to modernfertility.com toast30 you can
get 30 off your test plus you can get
reimbursed for the test through your FSA
or HSA if you want kids today or maybe
one day in the future clinically sound
information about your body can help
make the decision that's right for you
there's never a bad time to start
planning for the future whether you're
thinking about kids or not the game
about kids this is information that's
becoming now really accessible to you
through Modern fertility and it's really
affordable when you go to the doctor
there's like so much torture you have to
wait in line talk to receptionist you
have to spend a lot of money modern
fertility comes straight to your door
it's much more affordable and you're
getting the same information like
insights into your ovarian reserve tons
of important factors so right now modern
fertility is offering oh my God you
scared me with that sneeze
oh my God right now modern fertility is
offering our listeners thirty dollars
off the test when you go to
modernfertility.com toast300 it's a
limited time offer for thirty dollars
off and that means that your test will
cost just 149 when hormone testing at a
fertility clinic it can cost three times
as much thirty dollars off your
fertility test at modernfertility.com
toast30
modernfertility.com toast30 all right
are you ready for dear toaster Jacks
we've got three great submissions can't
wait hey girlies love you both
here's some backstory I've been with my
boyfriend who's 24 for two years and we
recently moved in together I love him so
much he's amazing no complaints however
he has this bear
he's had bear which is literally his
name and his gender as a boy he said
bear since he was a baby and has slept
with it ever since bear no sorry
whenever we were long distance it didn't
bother me because when I spent the night
he put bear away and he never brought it
to a sleepover but now that we live
together he asks to sleep with it and it
makes me so uncomfortable to add to the
weirdness he loves to hug it put his
nose to its nose and the whole
relationship is just so weird to me I
don't know what to do because no matter
how much I complain he still sleeps with
the bear I understand the attachment but
at what point do you let something go
what should I do the bear has to go
it's giving Balenciaga oh
Jackie no the thing is is like there are
grown ass adults out here with like
blankie and Bear
yes there is well like maybe there's a
handful yeah no there's not like a
that's not a thing it's not like a thing
that works unless it's [ __ ] Ted and
he's hilarious songs with you and
driving you to your work this is
unacceptable he you got he needs to go
to therapy you can go with him if you're
really interested in making this
relationship work but this is not like a
fully formed adult sorry Jackie I want
you to know that that's a really hot
take like there are a lot of people I'm
sure a lot of our listeners like they
have blankies that are literally being
held on by a thread I just want you to
know one it's different if it's a girl
like everything else level two there's a
difference between having like a
Sentimental item from your childhood
like if you still have your blanket from
your childhood and like you keep it like
that is cool sweet to sleep with it
every single night put your nose to its
nose call it bear and it's like the
third person in your throttle that is a
shade too far
I agree and you like you have this like
transference of like dependence on this
thing and that is a psychological thing
that you need to like go to therapy for
to become like a dependent independent
adult not like that's what a
two-year-old does with a bear they they
like transfer their like love and like
neediness almost onto like an inanimate
object which is actually a really good
thing it helps them like detach from
being so needy with their parents they
transfer and then they become
independent your boyfriend hasn't done
that yet and like he needs to get there
it sounds like he needs to unburden
himself of this bear
yeah it's not and like especially if
you're not someone who's like down with
it and like thinking that it's fine like
you wrote into us like it bothers you
it's hindering his adult relationships
and at a certain point it's gonna be me
or bear I think that he should get like
uh therapy to help him make this
transference and then but and he'll
transfer all of this baroness onto you
which also is kind of unhealthy because
he still has never been independent no
that's a good point like therapy I feel
like is probably the best advice that we
could give this girl that's a really
good call
um we're also just not people who can
relate to this whatsoever like we don't
have blankies like at camp like all
these girls had like their blankies and
we were like 16 17 and they were like
literally pieces of string like they had
been determined but like I can't okay
first of all if you're a camper at Camp
the maximum you could be is 15. but if
you're like a you could also be an eight
year old if you're an eight-year-old
with your blankie from home at camp like
that makes sense you are homesick this
is I'm talking about like 16 year olds
well I don't okay well I don't know who
you're talking talking about and I feel
like you're exaggerating and if you're
not like that I'm not exaggerating I
don't even want to say but like
literally I just saw a real yesterday of
our girl Rach parcel she brought her
blankie on vacation there in Hawaii so
I'm telling you it's like a really
common thing that like it's not as crazy
as you think it is it's her blankie from
her childhood or it's her favorite
blanket from home that like she's going
away from home and she wants a picture
it's a blankie like I'm telling you
you're not understanding like this is a
very common thing please let me Reach
This Tick Tock right now I if anybody's
gonna convince me otherwise it's rage
send me the tick tock where I am out
right now and I'll tell you why it's
different Jackie she put it on reels and
you're supposed to be a reals person
well Chevy didn't share the reels to her
story
look literally she posted something
about her husband it was very funny
actually maybe it was on Tick Tock sorry
yeah yeah I was trying to get him if I'm
saying I don't know Rachel's content no
I'm telling you here
waking my husband up with my baby
blanket Marcia to see his reaction so
she has a name for it it's her baby okay
so she knows it's weird it's a crusty
old blanket and he throws it across the
room and says get it off of me
because they acknowledge that it's weird
no I by the way there is self-awareness
it's there's a little bit of dysfunction
and like something psychological but I
just wanted you to know like this is not
like this is for people our age like
it's actually weird like a lot of people
have this
they're not okay I'm sorry and the thing
is about Rachel I'm not worried about
her and her dependence on her blankie
because she's like a fully like she has
a thriving life and a full life and she
is like she's okay it seems
um but this is like a 24 year old man
who's like venturing into adulthood and
like this is a critical time for him and
he needs to transfer his dependence from
bear and I'm sorry and also like there's
something like a little less weird about
it when it's a girl versus a boy Jackie
100 like when it's and by the way when
it's rage versus a lay person no of
course and we also need to discuss like
how One of the benefits of living in the
patriarchy is like we can do things like
we can get away with stuff we can get
away with stuff so I don't whenever you
want to you know
disestablish the patriarchy I support
the movement but keep in mind there are
a few benefits and your blankie is one
of them yeah and we're getting away with
it but
now for long not if I have anything to
say about it all right are you ready for
our next one how you doing ladies I have
a predicament my husband and I have been
together for almost four years at the
very beginning like three or four months
in I was super insecure and I got on his
phone one night while he was sleeping I
muted literally every single female on
his following list that I was even a
little threatened by I knew he'd
probably realize if I unfollowed them so
that's why I just muted them now we've
been together for so long and I've been
to therapy and I feel secure in our
relationship I mean we're literally
married now but the other day I
remembered that I did this and now I
just don't know what to do should I tell
him should I secretly take his phone
again and undo it should I just leave it
alone and take this to the Grave I feel
bad because some of the girls were his
close friends and I'm even close friends
with some of them now and I don't know
what to do help
honestly I feel like if you come out
with it like you will look a little
crazy like don't come out with it the
only thing that you could maybe do if
you need to feel the need to do
something is slowly one by one unmute a
few people you can't undo it all at once
he'll get this flood of the key models
hacked no and he'll just be like hey
what's all this puss like no but I also
don't need to unmute anyone like a
famous model leave them muted but like
close friends like who aren't posting
like titillating stuff like but I think
you need to do it you need to roll it
out slowly but yeah it gives more
opportunity for you to be caught yeah
that's also true but it has to be done
very stealthily like a spy
like a spy one by one one at a time and
go from ants go marching one by one
hurray hurray hurray
yeah no I like low-key like agree like
that what you did what you had to do at
the time like for yourself and for your
man but now you can acknowledge it it
was crazy and that's called growth and
I'm really proud of you who's to say
that like you reached this place
not like perhaps you reached this place
of confidence and and and
certainty and security because of what
you did no for sure
you allowed you to get to this place to
thrive environment uninterrupted by
bikini models you did what you had to do
for you and your man and your
relationship and I'm proud of you
and now you're you know grown enough
to to make some changes again
absolutely
slowly do not roll out
overall messages do not tell him like
you will look so crazy
oh no that sounds I don't know what you
do in your own time is Nobody's Business
by your own
don't sweat it I think we could learn a
lot from you I agree
hey girlies and Streisand Brothers my
bestie at work has to slept with Jackie
you're gonna like like actually vomit
okay oh God my bestie at work has this
little baking side hustle and she's very
good every Christmas her and her mom
spend a weekend before Thanksgiving
baking hundreds of Christmas cookies of
all kinds to give out as gifts to their
friends and families over the holidays
this year was my first year getting a
full-size box for my family other people
at the office who got boxes included her
entire team of like 10 plus people a few
of our bosses a couple of peers the day
she gave to me I was headed to my
parents for the night for a birthday
dinner my family knows her baking so
well and they were just so excited about
the cookies the next morning I sprang up
out of bed so excited to dine on the
cookies went to my surprise as I entered
the kitchen the box was gone
I come to find out that two cockroaches
had crawled out of the box earlier that
morning when my parents were having
cookies with their coffee and they of
course had to throw out the entire box
basically fumigate the kitchen
I'm positive that it did not come from
my parents because my mom hired an
exterminator later that day and they
confirmed that there were no bugs in the
house I'm horrified because she gave
this box to a ton of other people at
work including Executives in our group
I'm definitely the closest person to her
who got a box but I'm so torn do I just
stick it to the Grave with me or do I
find a way to tell the friend that her
box was a cockroach Motel sincerely a
toaster who can never look at Christmas
cookies the same way
that's horrible just tell her like I
don't know because like
it still could have been you like that
no it just sounds like she exhausted
every option like I'm operating under
the premise that it was not you and like
you should just tell her because like
she made you she made you go through
this and so also she knows like don't
ever give me one of your roach-laced
cookies again I do want to say when I
are done I won't tell everyone else
because I don't want to start a panic
but you have Unleashed
Mania in the office now I'm not gonna
tell anyone because it's Rochella
Rochella actually maybe tell honestly
like to me this is so unforgivable like
get your disgusting [ __ ] cookies that
I never asked for away from me it's so
like extra to like make box of cookies
for everyone even though like nobody
asked you know but she wants your
homemade cookies no but it's like no the
girl if I don't know you like if you're
not if to me it's like if you're not
Olivia or you're not like my close
friend and you're like bringing me some
homemade Goods like
so then it's a roach infested like you
need to be stopped dead in your tracks
so this is what you do this is the plan
you tell the biggest yenta at the office
yeah the biggest gossip that there were
but you but [ __ ] you better be a
hundred percent certain they came from
her box like I almost want you to send
your like to do uh because you can't
start to swimmer about someone and it's
like not true
you need to find a way to confirm that
it was in another box like you need to
have proof because we're not going to be
slandering homemade chefs
and you tell the biggest gossip in your
office that
you got your box and there was two
roaches in it and then you let the chips
fall where they may
okay I just want to say you had a few
things wrong one the girl said like this
these girls cookies are really good it's
like a treat to go and she's not
imposing her box of cookies on people
like she's very talented two um I
actually couldn't agree with you last
like I think the best baked goods in the
world come from people who are like
full-time workers who happen to be
really good at baking uh Casey pie
yeah but like I
I don't think Casey pie Casey no she's
she had me has a business
and then she's like really good at
making pies so like a little side hustle
she'll like sell a couple pies during
the holidays some of the best baked
goods are from people who have side
hustles yes correct yes she didn't sell
these cookies
well this year was like a gift but I do
think she said side hustle it literally
says side hustle so it's like a side
business and then for her gifts for her
you know co-workers she you know in lieu
of a bottle of wine made cookies okay
okay okay I'm with you I'm following
continue so I just want to say it wasn't
an imposition but the Cockroaches does
change things it is now an imposition
I don't know what to tell you like to
bring a cockroach into someone's home is
an unforgivable thing unforgivable
because it's a problem for life they
like if you have if your cockroach
problem is to the point that you can't
take a box out of your kitchen without
you sneaking in then I'm sorry they are
crawling all over the place and you have
to know about it and you're knowingly
making baked goods in your cockroach
Hotel
for your friends and family
because you're right for them to have
gotten in the Box it must oh my God I
can't talk about this my back is
starting to tingle I'm the wrong person
but here's the thing I'm the wrong
person to ask about this because I take
such offense like if this were the if
this happened to me I would lose my mind
and so I'm out of my mind I can't answer
you what to do for me this is reason
enough to let go no contact with this
person forever like it's really what
would you tell anyone would you tell her
what would you do
I think I feel like telling her you made
the best point like if they get into the
box like they're not okay like they're
she must know about the roach problem
like if it's that rampant so you're
telling her something she already knows
and chose to ignore
yeah and children to use as a kitchen
that's diabolical stuff
unless I don't know she took it on the
train I don't know you know what was the
Journey of the box
no for real
um I getting A tingle down my spine I
cannot talk about riches I'm staring at
the floor right now because now I'm
anticipating an attack so I'm man enough
to say that like my advice here is
maybe not the best advice because like I
would take this so deeply personal like
to me this is this is a trigger for me a
roach
a roach hotel in my like that is a
trigger for me so maybe someone in the
comments can tell us what's best here
because I can't see clearly out of this
one we're too triggered we're too
triggered well that was your toaster
thank you to everyone who wrote in again
that email is deertoesters gmail.com try
and keep your submission brief simply
need to know information for the best
chance of getting on the show that is
our show thank you guys so much for
listening to the toast the millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so that's Spotify iTunes Stitch or
public radio I have radio guess box all
the places maybe listen to podcasts find
us the tosaliba five-star review about
how we
talented we are have an amazing hump day
we'll see you tomorrow for our final
episode of the week because tomorrow
night I am in Delaware for one of the
final shows of the N log tour so four
episodes this week not five and we're
back on Monday
oh and are you gonna be in New York on
Monday
yeah girl he's back together
Ochi recipe hey hey love you guys have
an amazing day and we'll see you
tomorrow bye